what do you make of Harry's visit at
least listen this visit was a blink and
you miss it visit I mean he was here for
just over 24 hours really there is still
a very real rift at the heart of the
House of Windsor from touchdown to take
off I'm outside Buckingham Palace as we
break down Harry's Whirlwind visit to
the UK with two Royal experts all right
let's start with his arrival at the
coronation at 10 38 a.m UK time
did you make of Harry's arrival walking
in to Westminster Abbey Harry had always
been a beloved member of the royal
family so to arrive at this very
celebratory occasion and not be on
speaking terms with so many people
within his own family it made for a very
uncomfortable arrival did he and William
make any eye contact at all I couldn't
see any sign of eye contact whatsoever
while Harry sat three rows back often
hidden by Princess Anne's Red Feather
William was front and center and
kneeling before his father the king hi
William Prince of Wales pledge my
loyalty to you and faith and truth I
will bear unto you after Prince William
kissed him the king smiled you have to
wonder what that moment felt like for
Prince Harry who was exiled to the third
row then an unexpected moment Prince
Harry likes so many in the crowd
pledging allegiance to his father
but here's a a royal moment you didn't
see on TV Harry didn't stick around for
long we can now see Harry leaving the
church he is alone by himself his family
already on their way to Buckingham
Palace he was out of Westminster Abbey
within 10 minutes of the ceremony finish
down the street you can see the king's
coach
passing parliament in Big Bend meanwhile
Prince Harry still standing in front of
Westminster Abbey Harry waited outside
for his car for 10 minutes smiled
nervously and then he climbed into the
back seat of a BMW by himself it was
clear that he had made his own plans and
his own sort of arrangements to get back
to California on time there are several
memes that were made of Harry's facial
expressions first trying to look around
Anne's hat but also the one like he had
seen a ghost what do you think about
those memes well how do you seen a ghost
or was he being ghosted I know Harry
pretty well I think Kevin that inside he
was feeling as crumpled as his Dior seat
looked from the back and that was pretty
crumbled it has gone viral the faces he
was making during the coronation what
can you tell us with Harry we see
sadness so we see the eyebrows come
together we see the the mountain troop
so he was experienced a combination of
kind of frustration anxiety Harry who
flew commercial Marshall landed back in
La at 6 45 Pacific time he did make it
home in time for the early evening in
Montecito probably to tuck his little
son into bed just in time before the end
of the day Megan who stayed behind to
celebrate Archie's fourth birthday was
spotted on Sunday hiking near their home
in Montecito Royal sources say the King
Charles actually made a toast to Prince
Archie for his fourth birthday and sort
of acknowledged the Sussex family who
wasn't there there was a place set at
the table there was an open invitation
he didn't take it that was his choice do
you think Archie's birthday was used as
an excuse I think RT's birthday was very
convenient aside from all the Harry
drama the other thing we can't stop
talking about William and Kate's
adorable kids who gave us these shots
all weekend long
and then this morning
Kate is a patron of the Scout
Association over here in the UK and they
took all three children to a scouting
Center Louis this was his first public
engagement now Prince William didn't
carry out public engagement until he was
eight yeah that is Peak Louis shooting
arrows driving a digger with Dad and of
course acting out
meanwhile Charlotte and her woodworking
brother George had the same Poise we saw
Saturday cued the king's page fulfilling
his duty for the coronation Prince
George helping to carry his
grandfather's robe into Westminster
Abbey
the nine-year-old who's second in line
to Grandpa's Throne stood up very
straight alongside his fellow Pages they
include Camilla's grandsons Freddie
Louis and Gus he was the youngest one
everyone else's teenagers he really took
it seriously you could see him sort of
checking that every crease was outside
of that robe it's also a preview of what
he may one day experience himself I
think for princess Charlotte we really
see her taking after her mother Kate you
know she's so composed so put together
she sort of mastered that sort of Royal
approach to public appearances at a
really young age and check out Charlotte
matching her late grandma giving this
diana-like stare but you gotta hand it
to Charlotte Prince William revealed his
daughter was very tired after fulfilling
her most important role quote making
sure her little brother behaved she took
him by the hand and showed him what he
needed to be doing she's a pretty
formidable little princess she's the one
that keeps him in line it's sweet to be
be able to see that sort of sibling bond
between the two and I hope that stays
because as we've seen with William and
Harry it is volatile in this environment
Louis was seen yawning during the
service and at one point disappeared why
well he's five we actually had a little
note from Kensington Palace saying that
he may retire for the entire ceremony
that was the warning that we were given
he was removed for about 20 minutes and
once he was back in he was sort of just
taking it all in but yes there were
yawns there was a little bit of
restlessness at times the two-hand wave
on the balcony was right was pretty good
yes Louis took the note to Wade from his
dad and note to the Palace Louis hates
flyovers and gets sad when leaving the
party I love photographing the children
people love seeing the children Getty
Images Royal photographer Chris Jackson
captured this spectacular shot a
previously unseen angle of the newly
crowned king and queen and to kind of
take that photo from the room behind
saying it's never been done before was
just so special and it was great to see
the reaction I was pretty nervous about
taking the picture I was just
concentrating on getting that that shot
it's what the crowd wanted it was
definitely one of those kind of country
moments
of course there's Secrets behind many of
these picture-perfect moments including
Kate and Charlotte's ultimate twinning
moment I don't know many little girls
that get to wear bespoke Alexander
McQueen they were both twinning it in
Ivory it had also been embroidered with
the thistle the daffodil the Shamrock
and the rose represent England Ireland
Scotland and Wales and they both had
these matching headdresses which were
designed by Jess Collette with Alexander
McQueen Alexander McQueen designed
Kate's 2011 wedding dress the Princess
of Wales also paid tribute to the league
Princess Diana with these earrings Megan
made sure she wasn't left out of the
discussion she wore a subtle nod to the
people's princess during her Montecito
hike she was wearing the Cartier tank
watch that once belonged to Princess
Diana I think on a day that was all
about Charles and Camilla those little
nods to Diana was just their way of
saying that she wasn't completely
forgotten
I spoke exclusively with Queen Cabela's
dress designer Bruce Oldfield there was
a secret pocket don't ask me what you
wanted to put in the pocket but I'm sure
it's a tissue or something like that
there was a
sealed and her dogs were embroidered in
there yeah they were okay one of the
dogs is the Kings and one of them is
hers and his is called Bluebell and hers
is called best but don't ask me which
one is which
Camilla wore this Priceless piece known
as the coronation necklace it is made up
of 26 massive diamonds and was worn by
the late Queen Elizabeth at her own 1953
coronation and when it came to her
crowning moment may thy servant Camilla
who wears this Crown be filled by thine
abundant grace Camilla wore the Queen
Mary's crowd which is made up of more
than 2 200 diamonds King Charles wore
two starting with Saint Edward's Crown
God Saves The King
it is a Priceless piece probably the
most important piece in that Royal
collection you only get to see it on a
coronation and in fact Charles only
wears that crown for about an hour Katy
Perry also put a royal spin on her
coronation outfit her lilac Vivian
Westwood Ensemble is drawing comparisons
to this 1997 look worn by Princess Di
Katie was the selfie queen of the event
and went viral with this moment
obviously she didn't see the seating
chart looking for where she is supposed
to sit during the ceremony in
Westminster Abbey Katie was in on the
joke tweeting don't worry guys I found
my seat other stars in attendance Emma
Thompson was one of the first
celebrities cited and she was with her
husband Greg wise did you know that he
played Lord mountbatten in the crowd
doesn't that lift the spirits now first
lady Jill Biden arrived with her
granddaughter Finnegan and their outfits
were chosen to show support for the
Ukraine there's Oscar winner Dame Judy
denge Downton Abby's Maggie Smith Lionel
Richie looked Royal and Regal he did a
full-on photo shoot before he arrives
but this was the scene outside
Westminster Abbey thousands rallying in
protests one even had to be carried away
by his hands and legs but that wasn't
the only drama a royal Navy officer and
flag bearer collapsed and had to be
carried away on a stretcher more than 20
million watched the coronation I spoke
exclusively with body language expert
Darren Stanton who explained exactly
what happened here with the King what
did you make of his body language when
he first pulled up in the carriage
according to a lip reader he was upset
and he was saying you know why can't we
ever be on time so when he pulled up
what we saw was his face was quite pale
which says it's had a shift in emotion
and then also his eyebrows came together
and then his lips pierced now that's
what we call a micro expression of anger
it's an unconscious gesture that we
can't control so that would tie in with
what the lip reader says how about when
he was with William and he seemed to say
to him my boy we have this prolonged eye
contact when we look at in the eyes for
more than five seconds it means that we
have trust and deep rapport with that
person William and Kate I feel they're
being prepared to become king and queen
and I've been assessing these for about
a decade and we've seen their confidence
growing great leads
foreign